c'est comme ça tous les jours depuis la
mi novembre un convoi policier à haute
sécurité et score d'un fourgon blindé
qui transportent celui qui était
l'ennemi public numéro 1 de narco
trafiquant le plus recherché du monde
le plus puissant depuis pablo escobar il
s'agit de roy keane
archivaldo guzmán zohra dit el chapo
guzmán
el chapo veut dire le petit trapu il a
été capturé par les soldats mexicains en
janvier 2016 et extradé un an plus tard
aux états unis où il finira probablement
sa vie en prison
en ce moment il est en isolement dans la
prison la plus sécuritaire d'amérique
la metropolitan correctional center
qu'on surnomme le petit guantanamo et
tous les jours ils se déplacent via le
pont de brooklyn spécialement fermée à
la circulation jusqu'à la cour de
district de brooklyn
les médias mexicains couvrent le procès
au jour le jour le tribunal de brooklyn
est une destination touristique et la
sécurité et maximum share unit fleurs et
détecteurs de gaz
tous les matins se présente fidèlement
au tribunal la jeune épouse du chapeau
emma coronel à ispoure ancienne reine de
beauté mexicaine puis ses deux avocats
ils n'ont pas la tâche facile c'est un
personnage mythique et maintenant on
veut nous faire croire qu'il est le seul
narcotrafiquants au monde
el chapo c'est d'abord le roi de
l'évasion une première fois en 2001 il
s'échappe de la prison la plus
sécuritaire du mexique dans une
cargaison de linge sale
grâce à des complicités dans le
personnel sa deuxième évasion est encore
plus spectaculaire
il s'enfuit par un trou creusé sous sa
toilette et un tunnel d'un kilomètre et
demi
éclairez même climatisée est pourvu
d'une moto sur rails jusqu'à cette
maison dans la campagne de la bonne
matière pour télésérie cette fois
personne ne m'arrêtera
je vous propose de former une fédération
sous les ordres d'une personne n'échappe
aux gousses man 61 ans fait face à 17
chefs d'accusation dont trafic de 154
tonnes de cocaïne vers les états unis
pour un profit de 14 milliards de
dollars + complot pour meurtre et
blanchiment d'argent
ce qui pourrait lui valoir la prison à
vie il a plaidé non coupable
pendant toutes les audiences joaquín
guzmán restent généralement impassible
quelquefois il sourit légèrement mais il
ne dit jamais un mot
ses avocats tentent de convaincre le
juge et les 12 jurés dont l'identité est
protégée
quel chapeau n'était pas le vrai chef du
cartel de sinaloa
mais un exécutant ce qui a été démenti
par jesús fils mtc mbada le frère de son
ancien associé devenu rival qui l'a
désigné comme le plus puissant des
narcotrafiquants un autre ancien
complice le colombien aurait cifuentes a
expliqué comment ils négociaient des
cargaisons de cocaïne avec la guérilla
des farc pour le compte du chapo guzmán
et pedro flore est chicago a décrit
comment il avait étendu un marché de
centaines de millions de dollars de
cocaïne dit chapeau vers détroit
philadelphie et washington s'étaient -
l'accusation sont tous des
narcotrafiquants condamné et repenti et
puis pavé dans la mare
l'avocat du chapeau jefferies rischmann
a accusé le président mexicain sortant
enrique peña nieto et son prédécesseur
felipe calderon d'avoir touché des
centaines de millions de dollars de
pots-de-vin du cartel ce qui a fait les
manchettes au mexique sans toutefois
surprendre les spécialistes de la
question on peut dire en termes généraux
qu'il n'y a pas de trafiquants qui
existent sans la protection du
gouvernement
l'ex-président mexicain rapidement et
formellement tout démenti précisant que
c'est lui qui avait réussi la capture du
chapter ousmane
chaque soir la jeune épouse du chapeau
quittent le tribunal sans répondre aux
questions des journalistes mais elle
refuse rarement un ego portrait avec des
admirateurs les audiences du procès
doivent encore durer un ou deux mois
jean michel leprince radio canada
montréal